[Música]
bienvenidos a este programa especial en
france 24 los ojos del mundo estarán
puestos en qatar entre noviembre y
diciembre de 2022 es para la copa del
mundo de fútbol la primera que se va a
celebrar en medio oriente un mundial
impensado que se va a llevar a cabo 12
años después de su adjudicación en medio
de múltiples cuestionamientos que van
desde acusaciones de corrupción en la
elección de la sede hasta críticas por
las pobres condiciones laborales y de
derechos humanos en el país las
repasamos en el siguiente informe
de binner tuvo ganas
de juventud fifa world cup es capaz
el 2 de diciembre de 2010 el mundo
presenció atónito como la fifa entregó
su principal torneo a un país de medio
oriente y el mundo árabe por primera vez
qatar un pequeño estado de la península
arábiga sin tradición futbolística se
impuso a eeuu y se quedó con el
mundial-2022 una elección que rápido
disparó sospechas de presiones políticas
y corrupción y marcó la antesala del
estallido del fifa gate la megacausa
impulsada por la justicia estadounidense
que provocó la caída de veteranos casi
que es del fútbol como joseph blatter y
michel platini
pero aún con los cambios en la
diligencia de la fifa sostuvo acatar
contra viento y marea aceptando incluso
mudar la competencia de manera inédita a
finales de año para evitar las
temperaturas extremas del verano catarí
that never went nunca había presenciado
algo así un año antes del comienzo todos
los estadios están listos y son de
vanguardia son hermosos los preparativos
están en curso por supuesto todavía hay
mucho trabajo por hacer carreteras
hoteles y más pero nos estamos
preparando para darle la bienvenida al
mundo a qatar qatar qatar ha apelado al
deporte como una forma de soft pauer y
ha rodeado su postulación de embajadores
reconocidos como david beckham papu o
samuel eto'o pero el recelo
internacional persiste el país es
cuestionado por su pobre récord en
derechos humanos la falta de respeto por
la diversidad y sobre todo las carencias
de su sistema laboral sostenido casi en
su totalidad por trabajadores migrantes
en condiciones cercanas a la esclavitud
aunque bajo la vigilancia global qatar
ha implementado mejoras para los obreros
y para acabar con el sistema de
patrocinio caffa las organismos
internacionales las consideran
insuficientes y regla más transparencia
especialmente en las investigaciones de
las muertes de trabajadores inmigrantes
varios de ellos ligados a la
construcción de infraestructuras para el
mundial si bien reconocemos que ha
habido algunos avances legales
importantes la aplicación en el terreno
sigue siendo muy débil lo que deja a
muchos de los trabajadores migrantes aún
a merced de empleadores sin escrúpulos
en este escenario el mundial promete
jugarse tanto dentro como fuera del
campo diversas federaciones se han
realizado manifestaciones para reclamar
mejoras en derechos humanos y la de
dinamarca prometió extender las durante
su participación en suelo qatarí
para profundizar sobre los diversos
aspectos de este mundial estamos con
rodrigo sedano de la redacción de france
24 rodrigo bienvenidos en el informe
mencionábamos este sistema laboral del
caf a la que tiene una especie de
patrocinio que ata al empleado con el
empleador el cuáles son las reformas que
ha implementado o qatar para modificarlo
y de qué se trata este sistema si fuera
antes de hablar del sistema vamos a
irnos al primer momento porque todas
estas reformas vienen tras una denuncia
de varios organismos de asociaciones
obreras a qatar en 2014 con ello qatar
llegó a un acuerdo con la organización
internacional del trabajo en 2017 por el
que se comprometía a reformar su sistema
laboral entre 2018 y 2020 a que se
comprometía exactamente qatar pues lo
primero como bien has dicho a reformar
este sistema kafala que no es más que un
sistema que unía a los trabajadores con
su empleador pero hasta tal punto que
los empleadores podían permitir se
podían prohibir a los trabajadores salir
del país sin su permiso y podían
prohibir les cambiar de trabajo se han
llegado incluso a escuchar denuncias de
robos de sustracciones de los pasaportes
para que los trabajadores no salieran de
qatar y hay otros cuatro cambios
principales que son los correspondientes
a la mejora de los salarios la mejora de
inspecciones y de condiciones laborales
la prevención y persecución del trabajo
forzoso y la reforma para dar más voz a
los trabajadores para que puedan contar
sus problemas bien en amnistía
internacional- es una de las
organizaciones que ha estado dándole
mayor seguimiento a la situación laboral
en qatar y ya ha sacado hace poco un
último informe sobre la situación en ese
país
y destaca que estas reformas en la
práctica está costando implementar las
cuáles son los dos aspectos que denuncia
esta organización este informe del que
habla es un informe muy elaborado de más
de 40 páginas que gira en torno a lo que
has dicho aunar una denuncia muy
concreta y es que todo lo que hay sobre
el papel al día a día de los
trabajadores pues no se ha llegado a
implantar y el primer punto de todo son
cinco puntos principalmente los que
denuncia la organización amnistía
internacional el primero es que desde
agosto de 2020 se cambió esta casa por
un sistema laboral más acorde al siglo
21 y realmente los trabajadores siguen
dependiendo de sus trabajadores en
cuanto de sus proveedores de trabajo en
cuanto a su estatus legal en el país del
golfo el segundo lugar es el robo de los
salarios qatar se comprometió y de hecho
creó una plataforma para que todos estos
pagos de salarios estuvieran
monitorizados pero ahora a la hora de la
verdad lo que indica amnistía
internacional es que esto no está
sucediendo que incluso con la pandemia
el robo de salarios el trato entre
empleador y trabajador se está haciendo
por detrás de la ley y los trabajadores
denuncian que no están recibiendo los
salarios que merecen aún cuando qatar
también dijo e implantó un salario
mínimo que estaría tanto para qataríes
como para extranjeros hay otro punto muy
importante y es el derecho a la
afiliación sindical de hecho qatar había
firmado varios acuerdos pero la verdad
esta afiliación simplemente es para
trabajadores qataríes y el punto más
importante es el de las muertes de
trabajadores que muchas veces captar
habla de muertes laborales sin más o
ataques al corazón pero nos indaga en
las causas no se permite a las familias
que inicien investigaciones y es muy
difícil saber cuánta gente ha muerto
realmente si existe toda una opacidad de
en torno a esas investigaciones y
estamos hablando también de un mundial
que se sostiene en estos trabajadores
porque se ha construido prácticamente
desde cero en cuanto a sus instalaciones
y con una inversión millonaria que sólo
puede permitirse un país con semejante
poder económico claro que estamos
hablando realmente de un país que no
tiene tradición futbolística y toda la
infraestructura relativa al mundial ha
tenido que construir de cero se calcula
que aproximadamente se ha podido gastar
ya entre 150 y 200 mil millones de
dólares realmente un monto muy
importante y en que se lo ha gastado
pues principalmente en los estadios de
fútbol ha construido 7 estadios nuevos y
ha renovado el estadio khalifa de doha
estadios nuevos destacan el estadio de
lusail que tendrán más de 85.000 tendrá
capacidad para más de 85 mil
espectadores y acogerá la final del
mundial que será el 18 de diciembre de
2022 el otro estadio que destaca es el
denominado como 974 tiene este nombre
por los 974 contenedores de transporte
marítimo que han utilizado para
construirlo además será un estadio
desmontable el primero de estas
características en el mundo
qué características hay con los estadios
pues todos están en un radio de 48
kilómetros en torno a doha la capital
del país y lo que se propone con esto es
que un aficionado si quiere puede haber
dos partidos de la misma jornada y que
no tenga que recorrer grandes distancias
para ello también se han construido
autopistas se ha reformado el aeropuerto
de qatar de doha perdón y además se ha
creado el metro de doha que ya está en
pleno funcionamiento
evidentemente el señor mundial con pocos
traslados a diferencia de otros que se
han desarrollado pasemos un poco
entonces ahora sí al aspecto deportivo
de qatar 2020 cierra con 13 selecciones
clasificadas la anfitriona y otras 12
sin demasiadas sorpresas si realmente
quizás la principal sorpresa es que esté
qatar no que como bien has dicho va a
jugar como invitada como selección
anfitriona por lo demás se han
clasificado para sí y argentinas las dos
más fuertes históricamente de américa
del sur y no hay muchas sorpresas de
momento en europa y 10 clasificadas y
salvo países bajos todas jugaron el
último mundial de rusia en 2018 y países
bajos tampoco es una selección nueva en
estos mundiales ya fue segunda
clasificada en el mundial de 2010 de
sudáfrica el resto de países de europa
está francia que es la actual campeona
del mundo está en países como portugal o
españa con alemania como inglaterra
también está la segunda actual del mundo
que es croacia y podemos ver un ritmo
prácticamente que podíamos esperar no
están las claras las selecciones que
hasta el momento podríamos esperar que
estuvieran clasificadas si quizás la
mayor pasan por los que todavía no han
asegurado su lugar
selecciones que tienen problemas como
italia como portugal o uruguay nombres
pesados del mundo del fútbol del mundo
exactamente portugal italia desde luego
en europa son una sorpresa porque
recordemos que son las dos últimas
campeonas de europa no no están en sus
mejores momentos actualmente pero tienen
posibilidad de clasificarse en la
repesca será sin embargo una repesca
difícil en europa habrá dos equipos que
sólo podrán acceder a tres plazas
clasificatorias se hará en un sistema de
tres playoffs que jugarán semifinales y
final de nuevo repito portugal italia es
fácil que puedan clasificarse pero no
tienen lugar a fallos si fallan están
fuera de este mundial y respecto a
sudamérica pues estamos viendo unas
eliminatorias muy igualadas pero en los
últimos partidos hemos visto que a la
baja porque destacan más los fallos de
muchas elecciones que las victorias
ahora mismo si no recuerdo mal entre el
cuarto clasificado que es colombia y el
cuarto puesto que es el que da acceso el
último que da acceso directo al mundial
y el noveno hay solamente cuatro puntos
a falta de cuatro
partidos
está muy disputado y como bien has dicho
uruguay está teniendo una racha nefasta
lleva cuatro derrotas en sus últimos
cuatro encuentros sí y habrá también que
esperar para ver si con la ausencia de
uruguay tenemos bajas de peso como la de
luis suárez y también qatar puede marcar
el fin de una era para muchos de estos
jugadores de peso que han dominado la
escena futbolística en los últimos años
especialmente de dos jugadores que no
son otros que leo messi y cristiano
ronaldo los dos jugadores que han
marcado devenir del fútbol en los
últimos años messi cuenta con 34 años
cristiano ronaldo 36 los dos han jugado
ya cuatro mundiales y podrían ser los
jugadores de esta época que llegaron a
jugar cinco mundiales algo que ha
conseguido muy poca gente voy a recordar
voy a repasarlo porque sólo cuatro
jugadores en la historia del fútbol lo
han conseguido dos mexicanos antonio
para baja al igual algunos recuerdan más
a rafa márquez un italiano que es una
leyenda del fútbol el portero luís
buffon y también un alemán lottar
matthaüs no sé si muchos lo conocerán
pero es además el jugador de la historia
con más partidos en los mundiales sí y
veremos entonces cuántos de estas
estrellas tenemos presentes en el
mundial gracias por este completo repaso
rodrigo la expectativa queda abierta
para el que será el primer magno evento
deportivo también pospandemia y que
además de requerir vacunación completa a
quienes viajen muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por habernos acompañado en este
programa tienen más deportes y más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
ah
[Música]